In this lesson, you learned about estimating population parameters with
confidence intervals and then analyzing whether or not a search and treatment
may have had an effect. So the examples we've used so far are the Bieber
tweeter, we wanted to see it's influence on klout scores. And then the other
treatment was the song about hypothesis testing for lesson nine, which I
seriously might do. After all this talk about it, I'm really curious about
whether or not this will work. I guess we'll just have to wait and see the
results of the poll where you rated your engagement and learning. Speaking of
which, that's the dependent variable. In the next lesson you'll learn how to
formalize the procedure of deciding whether or not the sample receiving
treatment had likely or unlikely statistics.